Biscuits, pancakes, cookies, cake, and
… a worldwide fungal infection. HBO's
"The Last of Us" is a thrill ride for gamers
and non-gamers alike, but those in-the-know
found some delicious surprises hidden in the
show's first two episodes. Spoilers ahead!
In "The Last of Us Part 2," Ellie
tells her girlfriend Dina that
Joel's favorite movie franchise is a
cheesy fictional '80s action series,
and she wants to use it as an olive branch
to help ease their strained relationship.
"What movie you guys gonna
watch? What's Joel into?"
"Uh, Curtis and Viper 2."
Later in the game, while taking shelter
with Dina and Jesse in a Seattle theater,
Ellie notices a "Curtis and Viper 4"
poster on the wall in one of the back
rooms and makes a comment to herself
that it was one of Joel's favorites.
In the show, fans will notice that the DVD
Sarah borrows for Joel on his birthday is
"Curtis and Viper 2," a film that obviously
holds importance in their relationship. So,
what's the plot? In "The Last of Us
Part 2," Ellie explains that it's about,
"Two former commandos that go rogue to fight
bad guys. And I think in [Curtis and Viper 2],
they go up against Russian spies
or something. [...] The young one,
Viper, he’s a trained ninja.
And he’s a complete badass."
"Oh, this is the one with the deleted scenes!"
"Yeah, imagine how bad those have to be."
This Easter egg makes the impact the
franchise has on Ellie and Joel in the
video game much more dynamic, as it
emphasizes what Ellie means to Joel
and how she has become a surrogate
daughter to him after Sarah's death.
Joel is eventually willing to share
his interests with Ellie — interests
that he once shared with Sarah,
whose absence he felt so much
that he could barely talk about her
in the original "The Last of Us."
When players wake up as Sarah in the video game,
they have the option to pick up a birthday card
in her bedroom. The card reads "Congratulations!"
and features an illustration of a green cartoon
dinosaur wearing a party hat. Sarah says
that she forgot to give the card to her dad,
but that worry is soon overshadowed
by the noises and chaos outside.
In the show, there is a shot of Sarah's bedroom,
and that same exact birthday card
can be briefly seen on her desk,
underneath some art supplies. The inclusion
of the art supplies in the scene could mean
that Sarah went to the trouble of hand-making her
father's card, a neat detail left out of the game.
Much like in the game, the shots of the birthday
card are not lingered on for very long. Sadly,
Sarah forgets to give it to
Joel after gifting him his
repaired watch and falling asleep
while watching a movie together.
Another neat detail from the opening: Sarah
is wearing a t-shirt for the fictional band
"Halican Drops" in both the show and the game.
In both versions, the list of tour stops on the
back include several locations that will
be important to the story down the road.
One of the most infamous scenes from the
original game comes when Tommy, Joel,
and Sarah are attempting to drive out of Austin
amidst the outbreak. When they end up downtown,
Tommy's truck is totaled by another vehicle
as the infected attack survivors and fires
break out across town, which leads to
Sarah injuring her leg in the escape.
Fans were likely expecting that very same
outcome to unfold in the show, given how
pivotal this event is in "The Last of Us" and
the fact that the scene mirrors the perspective
players experience in the game. Instead, the
writers changed the layout of the scene, opting
to first fake audiences out with an oncoming
truck that just narrowly misses Tommy's truck.
The chaos that flips Tommy's truck in
the show does not stem from another
road-bound vehicle. Instead, a plane crashes
in close proximity to Tommy, Joel, and Sarah,
which leads to debris flying at the truck
and causing it to crash. The switch-up gave
the scene a fresh feel in an episode that
was largely faithful to the original game.
Speaking of "faithful to the game" – here's
an easy-to-miss small detail that fans of the
game likely picked up on. When Joel is forced
to kill his infected neighbor with a wrench,
he discards it, likely out of disgust
for what he just had to do with it.
But in the "The Last of Us" game
series, wrenches can be used as weapons,
and the player is forced to discard them all the
time, since they only have a limited number of
uses. So switching out Joel killing his neighbor
Jimmy for Joel killing his neighbor Connie was
a fresh take that also nodded
at the mechanics of the game.
The world of "The Last of Us" is plunged into
chaos after the cordyceps fungal outbreak. In
the game, it begins with infected
crops in South America. However,
the show takes one of the main sources
of the spread — airborne spores — and
substitutes them with tendrils that grow out
of the infected. While it's unclear so far,
there must be some explanation for how
cordyceps took over the world in the
show. Fan theories circulating online
suggest one possible answer — flour.
"I was thinking we'd make some cookies!"
"Chocolate chip?"
"Raisin."
Joel and Sarah manage to avoid eating
flour-based products at least four
different times in Episode 1. First, they
find they have run out of it at breakfast
and make eggs instead of pancakes. Later,
they politely decline when their neighbors
offer them biscuits – the same biscuits
the infected neighbor ate. After that,
Sarah and Connie bake cookies together,
but Sarah doesn't take any because they
have raisins in them. Finally, Joel forgets
to pick up his birthday cake after work.
Beyond that, the creators of the
show may have hinted at all of
this in "The Last of Us Podcast."
There, Craig Mazin mentions that,
"Careful viewers of this episode will
be rewarded repeatedly because little
bits of breadcrumbs have been planted that are
going to pay off later in interesting ways."
Plus, it just so happens that the
world's largest flour mill is in
Jakarta, which appears to be at the
center of the outbreak on the show.
"Jakarta. Where is that? Middle
East? Doesn't ring a bell."
"Definitely a country. Maybe part of Asia?"
"Jakarta isn't a country."
Fans will just have to wait and
see how these enigmatic hints
play out in future episodes of "The Last of Us."
"Dad, you love biscuits."
"I do … But I'm on Atkins."
When Ellie awakens at the beginning of
Episode 2, a butterfly hovers above her.
This is a direct callback to various scenes in
the original game, where Ellie is constantly
enamored by the beauty of the butterflies and
fireflies living outside of the quarantine zone.
Butterflies become a symbol of hope,
which mirrors the hope that the Fireflies
have in Ellie's resistance to the Cordyceps
virus -- which they think may hold
the key to producing a viable vaccine.
"A vaccine."
Any child born after Outbreak Day is
brought into a world of immense violence
and cruelty. When Ellie is falling in love with
nature, taking the time to read comic books,
or cracking jokes about the adults, it's
a reminder that she's still just a kid
trying to piece together some semblance
of fun amid a hollow and deadly reality.
On top of all of that, before the events
of "The Last of Us Part II," Ellie gets a
tattoo of a butterfly to cover up the chemical
burn she gave herself to cover her bite scar.
"Um, just so it's out there, I can't swim."
In the original game, it's a running joke
-- and nuisance -- that Ellie can't swim. In
numerous missions, Joel is forced to push Ellie
across bodies of water using a wooden pallet.
In "The Last of Us Part II," flashbacks
show that Joel teaches her to swim and
she actually becomes quite skilled at it. She
even gets good enough to make a joke about her
past shortcomings when the two encounter
a stray pallet near a museum in Wyoming.
"Joel! Look! Wanna give me a ride?"
"Those days are long gone, kiddo."
When Joel, Tess, and Ellie
reach the hotel in Boston,
there is a lot of water separating them and
the stairwell they need to get to. Quickly,
Ellie notes that she can't swim because there
aren't many pools in the quarantine zone.
Annoyed by her point, Joel shows Ellie that
the water only goes up to his knees. It
remains to be seen whether or not Ellie's
inability to swim will become as big of a
plot point in the show as it was in the game
-- or if pallets will ever come into play.
In the game, as Joel and Ellie are about
to reach the hospital in Salt Lake City
where the Fireflies are stationed, they
stumble upon a group of giraffes in an
open field. It's one of the most beautiful
and enchanting parts of the first game,
and it gives the player a break from
the never-ending brutality. Players
can stand at the ledge and watch the
giraffes for as long as they'd like.
"It's got its ups and downs. You
can't deny the view, though."
In Episode 2 of the show, as Joel, Tess,
and Ellie are traveling across Boston and
heading toward the Capitol building, they
stop and take in the sights from a rooftop.
"You can't deny that view."
Fragments of the same composition that
soundtracked the giraffe encounter in the
game are used to score this scene – a subtle
link between the game and the show. Hopefully,
we'll hear it again (and see some
giraffes) in a later episode.